[Music]
[Applause]
welcome everybody to intility Arena here
on Oslo Norway we're about to play the
Christian pulisic bot that's right we're
officially announcing that one of the
biggest soccer stars one of the biggest
football stars in the world depending on
whether you call it football or soccer
is now a bot on chess.com we're super
excited to have this partnership with
him and I'm going to play chess against
the bot I think I get to be the first
one to ever do it so let's jump in and
start the game I'm gonna play E4 and
Christian Pops in the corner he says
I've played a lot of E4 games over the
last few days I'm ready all right I love
it I have to watch out for the fact that
my bee Pawn is hanging from the queen
that's a little spicy and if I Castle
he's got Knight F2 what is going on how
good is Christian's bot supposed to be
there are tactics I need to be aware of
over here like the fact that my king
could be wide open and I am taking that
very seriously I think I'm winning
oh wait there's my Rook is hanging
Christian is on the attack okay look out
this is fascinating I'm still winning
just barely but his bot is or am I
winning I don't even know I don't want
to lose to Christian's bot
um I don't actually see the wind there
wait looks like we're going into extra
time the pressure's on
off the crossbar so close to Checkmate
yeah
we're going for the attack King to G4
was necessary he didn't play it I've got
King G3 he's on the uh he's on the edge
of the field insert soccer reference I
don't I got my queen to E6 I thought my
Rook was on a B6 I just lost the game
I just lost the game
oh my gosh
oh my gosh what is wrong with me I'm
gonna lose to Christian pulis it just by
I feel like we need to like you know
edit the video to make sure that I win
this is hilarious
oh he blundered the pawn I still have a
chance
oh my gosh at least I'm not going to
lose any more to the Christian pool
Stitch bot I should be able to draw but
this game is probably going to go
forever nope ended in a draw
I mean I feel like that was the poetic
what does he say then fun game looks
like we should play again you're right
we should play again rematch Christian
because we drew
he says I've trained a lot for this game
mentally and physically lots of sleep
tons of practice I uh I am so shocked by
what happened there that I have to
redeem myself
I keep wondering I keep blundering oh my
gosh wake up Dan he's going to give
check I'll take take and play Knight in
but then he has Bishop
H6 why is Christian pools that just
bought so good
here we go that deserves that that
deserves some defense that's right now
we're gonna take and shake and bake and
this time I will not blunder my queen
I'll move away from Chuck mate we'll get
that Queen we're going to come over here
and clean up
I am not going to stalemate you
and I am the first human being on the
planet to beat the Christian pool of
such bot it feels good it feels good to
win one and a half out of two games
especially when you're a pathetic
International master who needs to do
things like that to feel good about
himself you know anyway this is actually
pretty awesome uh the Christian pulisic
bot is live on chess.com you can play it
go check it out play the bot and then
come visit me in my new office I'll be
here
[Music]